the website Mike calm has has a very
important article up right now about how
Victoria's Secret has normalized
discrimination and I mean obviously when
you think Victoria's Secret
you think normalization of
discrimination who doesn't now according
to Mike's Twitter account it says that
their Twitter account says since its
first show in 1995 no plus-size out
transgender or gender non-conforming
people have walked the Victoria's Secret
runway ever this is not a parody of no
this is a real this is a real thing that
liberals are upset about now and and you
know saying that there's never been
there's never been any men or obese
people walking down the Victoria Secret
runway that's a bit like saying well
since the first monster truck race in
1972 no unicycles or scooters have
competed ever whatever you think of a
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show the whole
point of the thing is for the skinny
attractive women to model underwear so
that's that's that's just why it exists
that's the point of it if you're looking
for a show where men model underwear as
my comp areas then I'm you you can find
that I mean I'm sure there are places
you can go and you can find that sort of
entertainment if you want but but but
but it's just that's not what Victoria's
Secret is all about see this is the
thing about about the left if you notice
nothing is ever allowed to be about
anything or for anything anymore have
you noticed that this is kind of the
consequence of this obsession with
fairness and diversity and inclusiveness
because because I'm just trying to think
of a way to explain this okay to anyone
who's a liberal and doesn't understand
everything okay everything in order to
be a thing in order to have a purpose
and an identity and a reason to exist
everything must be a certain thing and
therefore must exclude all of the things
that it is not okay
so for a thing to be a thing it must not
be the things that it isn't is this
making sense to you so the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show is specifically a
thing where attractive women walk down
the runway in underwear
now it's if that's not a thing that you
like or support or think is appropriate
or whatever fine
but when you say no this thing cannot be
that thing this thing must include all
other things it must include it must be
a celebration of diversity and
transgenderism and manhood and obesity
etc then you've just destroyed the thing
you haven't expanded it you haven't
diversified it you haven't made it know
you've just gotten rid of it you've
gotten rid of the thing the thing
doesn't exist anymore and that's what
the left is doing all over the place
they're erasing all lines all
distinctions all definitions and they're
thereby there they're just erasing
everything the sacrament the sacrament
of marriage is another example of this
phenomenon probably a much better
example actually than the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show but that that has
been the entire argument with marriage
it's you know marriage is a certain
thing if you make marriage into anything
then marriage no longer exists it's not
a thing anymore it has to it has to be a
specific thing which means it must
exclude the things that it isn't and
it's just liberals not that I'm trying
to really draw alcantara some between
the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show and
marriage I you know I'm just saying
these are examples and there are so many
of the left looking at a particular
thing and saying well no that's not
right because it excludes all the things
that it isn't it's which which it has to
okay that's just that's what it means to
be a thing
by the way I think this is more
important news yesterday was thank you
birth control day I don't know if you
celebrated I hopefully you did but it
was that yesterday was thank you birth
control day it was a day for people
people on the left mostly to stand up
for their right to use birth control and
and so on social media especially on
Twitter people were spending the day
tweeting about the wonders of birth
control about how much they need it how
much it has liberated them how much they
love it how they'll never let anyone
take it away from them I want to give
you a quick sample of some of the tweets
on the thanks birth control hashtag just
to give you an idea of what people were
saying the first one is from Hillary
Clinton she says reproductive rights are
human rights women's freedom to decide
whether and when to have children is
core to their liberty as human beings
today we celebrate the power to decide
someone else says thanks birth control
for allowing my husband and I had to
plan our family according to our
financial and emotional ability we both
believed it would be a disservice to our
family to have children we cannot
comfortably afford thanks birth control
for helping women achieve their goals
without putting their economic security
in jeopardy Planned Parenthood says your
body is your own and if not you can't be
truly equal or free access to birth
control is vital for people to live full
healthy lives and play in their futures
a couple of some some Democrat
politicians jumped in on the act a
woman's a woman's right to control her
reproductive future is critical to her
participation in all aspects of society
from our economy to our democracy we
must continue to protect that right and
stand up for reproductive health care so
on and so forth so you read these tweets
and it has a concern
what's your first reaction when you read
those tweets what's your reaction to
them what do you think I think I know
what your reaction is because I think
it's the same as mine and so you read
that or people say wide but birth
control is so important no one could
take it away from me
your reaction is okay and what's your
point you see this is this is one of the
one of the absolute weirdest things
about the left is this feverish paranoia
that they have that someone is going to
come and take their birth control away
they've been screaming for years that
that bad men are coming to steal their
birth control even though no one is
suggesting that nobody is is threatening
to take their birth control not one
person on the right is proposing that we
ban birth control that's not a thing
that's not a position that we hold no
one is arguing for that so it seems like
it seems like every conversation with
the left of our birth control it goes
like this the liberal will go will go
stay away from my birth control okay
you're not taking my birth control away
okay calm down I'm not it's my birth
control and you can't have it I don't
want birth control is mine and then
that's kind of how the conversation goes
and and conservatives are left just sort
of really confused that's what we don't
really know what to say because this is
not how did this ever come up we never
said anything about this liberals will
valiantly defend their right to use
birth control while literally no one
disputes that right they insist that no
one will take away their birth control
while literally no one is trying to take
it away there was an article in Daily
Beast yesterday that are well it was an
article it was that was written a year
ago and which was retweeted by The Daily
Beast yesterday and I'm surprised they
retweeted it because they should be
embarrassed by it because the the title
of the article was here's how we're
going to lose our birth control under
Trump okay well that was a year ago has
anyone lost their birth control under
Trump can you find me one single woman
in the United States who is now entire
unable to obtain birth control because
of Donald Trump I mean did this prophecy
come to fruition in fact we've had a
republican government for two years have
they - have they stolen birth control
from anybody have they sent the birth
control
you know enforcement agency in the
rating into people's homes into their
medicine cabinets to steal their birth
control pills has that happened look if
that's been happening I will I will
change my tune to I will apologize for
all of it all the mockery right now that
I'm engaging and if that is actually
happening if there are women who have
been who have been them scared senseless
when when when federal agents have burst
into their homes to confiscate their
birth control if that's going on then
you know forget everything I'm saying
but I don't think it is happening in
fact I don't think it's happened
anywhere in the country at all at all
okay so this this has not happened
unless The Daily Beast or any other
liberal can provide me example I'm going
to say that it is not happening
now what is this all about what is this
this this clamoring about birth control
and how important birth control is and
how they're not gonna let anyone take
away their birth control what is this
really about well it's about it's about
a couple of things we realize first of
all that when they say that
conservatives want to ban or get rid of
or take away their birth control what
they really mean is that conservatives
don't want to pay for their birth
control this is a conflation that that
people on the Left engage in quite a bit
where they conflate you know us not
wanting to pay for something with us
trying to take that thing away right
there are a lot of things that you do in
your life
that I would never try to prevent you
from doing and I would never support any
law that would prohibit you from doing
but that I still would not want to pay
for myself I mean there are a million
examples but almost everything you do in
your life
actually is something that you've go
ahead and do it I just don't to pay for
it that's all so you know liberals
pretend that they don't understand this
distinction I I think they must
understand it like they must understand
that if they came to me and said hey I
want to go to the movies and can you can
you give me $25 to pay for a couple of
movie tickets and if I say no I'm not
gonna pay for your movie ticket it
wouldn't make any sense for them to say
why are you trying to stop me from going
to the movies I have a right to go to
the movies how are you why are you
trying to prevent me you can't prevent
me I'm not trying to stop you I'm just
saying I don't want to pay for it that's
all because and why don't I want to pay
for it because I just got it's my money
I've got other things I'd like to pay
for it that's not high on my list of
priorities to make sure that you go to
the movies and when it comes to your sex
life you know as as you will remind us
all the time your sex life is your sex
life it's your business that's my point
it is your business in every sense of
the word it is not my business I don't
want to be involved in it
okay it's just it's not it's not on my
list of you know paying to make sure
that your sex life is facilitated that
is not on my list of concerns in my life
I've got many other things like we all
do that I need to pay for I got my kids
to take care of I got a family I got a
mortgage I got all these things right
and making sure that you can have sex
that's just not on the list I'm sorry
you know that's something that you got
to take care of be an adult and take
care of it yourself that's all is it
what what happened to consent isn't
consent important
I do not consent to being involved in
your sex life that's all
I don't consent to it it makes me
uncomfortable really to be honest with
you but as long as I'm not involved go
ahead take all the birth control you
want I mean I would take it in
accordance with the with the directions
on the bottle but do your thing I'm not
trying to stop you no one no one is
trying to stop you so that's the only
that's the only threat to birth control
that exists and it's not a threat to
birth control at all it's just people
are saying I don't want to pay for it
and you still want to pay for it and not
that this even matters but it should be
repeated that you don't even need
someone to pay for your birth control
because birth control is extremely easy
to obtain you can go to any I mean you
can get free birth control you could get
birth control for cheap you can I mean
there's birth control everywhere in our
society birth control is practically
raining from the sky I mean or door do
you need it - literally rain from the
sky before you'll admit that it that
it's plenty easy to obtain because it's
it I always say it all but rains from
the sky right now because you you can go
unless you live in the desert or
something unless you live in the desert
and you don't have a car and it's an
it's a-- it's a 900 mile walk through
the desert sands to get to your nearest
Walmart assuming you don't live in that
situation assuming you live just in
society with the rest of us you can go
anywhere and get birth control and
nobody will try to stop you
you know people on the left will often
make fun of a make fun of conservatives
claiming that we're always clinging to
our guns and insisting that nobody will
take our guns away even though they say
nobody's threatening to take our guns
away except that in that case people
actually do want to ban guns and
restrict guns and confiscate guns and
prevent people from buying guns and so
on and so forth that is a that is most
certainly a position that is held by
many people on the left there's no
denying it right meanwhile nobody on the
right holds the position that birth
control should be banned nobody hold you
would have to go back many years to get
to a time where banning birth control
was a proposal supported by any
significant number of people but we have
we have just that has not been the case
for a very long time
so what is this about well we know it's
as I said we know it's partly about the
in this conflation of I have a right to
it therefore I have a right to for you
to pay for it and so there's that going
on but the other part of it is it's just
it's just a really it's it's a it's it's
it's an absurd talking point for the
left to to put out there but if they can
convince people of it it's it's
obviously very convenient
it's a great way to get people mobile I
mean I mean if you're a liberal
politician and you can actually convince
your voters that Republicans are trying
to steal their birth control you're you
know if you can convince your voters of
that then clearly that's gonna be a
great way to mobilize them and and they
have been able somehow they've been able
to convince their voters of that and all
I would say to those voters is you know
you have Google you have the Internet
Jessica just go try go Google this
sometime to see how many Republicans
have actually proposed banning birth
control and what you'll find is that
none of them have and so you're fine
that's all you don't need to worry about
it all right one other thing I wanted to
mention Kath timp is a is a Fox News
personality she's she's the latest one
on fox news to be chased out of a
restaurant she was chased out of a bar
in Brooklyn earlier this week because
some liberals recognized her and so they
you know harassed her abused her
verbally and and chased her out and so
it goes the same story repeats over and
over and over again I do want to make
one point about this and I feel like
when it comes to these situations most
of what can be said has been said a
million times but we see that the left
strategy now is to be obviously just
completely intolerant of those who hold
opposing views to treat them like the
scum of the earth to harass and abuse
them and so on I think we should
understand why they're doing this though
what is the strategy why are they doing
us well obviously some of this is just
garden-variety two-year-old temper
tantrums basically just an inability to
express their anger or their opposition
civilly so there's obviously a lot of
that involved but there's more to it as
well there's a strategy here and it's
all about optics okay which sounds kind
of kind of intuitive because we think
well this is really bad optics on their
part to be to be protesting at people's
homes terrorizing their wives chasing
them out of rest
and all of that screaming at them when
they come to speak and college campuses
it seems like bad optics but it's only
bad optics as far as conservatives are
concerned we look at that and think wow
these people are nuts but I think the
strategy is it's not it's obviously it's
it's got its it's not targeted at us
it's it's targeted at other liberals and
maybe some people are on the left who
lean or in the middle and lean kind of
to the left I think the idea is to paint
the opposition as completely
Intolerable not even worth engaging
that's the idea is to send the message
that these people are so evil and so
wrong and so stupid in everything they
believe that there's nothing we can do
but banish them from society that
there's nothing weak they're not even
worth talking to if you see them at a
restaurant kick them out and that's
that's that's the idea and in some ways
it's a it's a smart strategy because
then the other side isn't given an
opportunity to actually say anything and
argue their point and and therefore show
that they are not evil and stupid stupid
and insane because you're just shouting
them down and chasing them away and
that's it so I think we should
understand that that there is that there
is a definite strategy here there's some
thought that goes into it it's it's it's
not we we make a mistake when we assume
that this is all just a temper tantrum
and nothing more it is partly that but
for the people who are incurred people
on the left we're encouraging this and
organizing this kind of stuff and and
and promoting it and fostering it there
is a strategy for them and that is to
send a message that these I that the
ideas these people hold are so terrible
so idiotic so irrational that there is
just nothing you can do with them but
exile them from civilized society
alright we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
and Godspeed